you know they always said women can just
do anything
as women we are just so respectable and
we can just do anything a man can do so
as you guys know I am a female athlete
and I did take professional
um Athletics really to quite high level
I went semi-prone England I had four
volleyball and I had a pro contract
offered to me in the fall I could have
went to a couple countries the YouTube
thing took off I did YouTube right but I
really understand
why professional women's sports are
frustrated because we do work like guys
I spent 16 years of my life training
like literally every day I would go to
school until three o'clock and then I
would I played two sports so I would go
to volleyball practice and I would go to
basketball practice so every day I would
train for four hours roughly a day a lot
of times I would drive an hour each way
so I wouldn't get home till like 10
o'clock at night so imagine spending
like six seven hours a day I on top of
school
for 10 plus years
um from the time I was 12 years old we
would travel out of state right so I was
at like 12 years old I would have a
tournament in Indiana I would have a
tournament in Vegas like I'd been to all
these states for volleyball
now imagine you do this you work so
incredibly hard and you become the top
one two percent of your sport right and
you usually think when you become the
top like two percent one percent in
skill of any profession that you're
gonna get paid but for women's sports
it's just not it I will never whine
about it because the market dictates
what we're paid and the truth of the
matter is I don't watch women's sports
most people don't want to watch women's
sports there's a reason we are paid less
but I understand where they're coming
from with their frustration about the
pay but the truth of the matter is it
just is what it is but what frustrates
me is when women are in a sport that
gets paid women that make it to the top
of their level right and actually and
because in other sports there's a little
bit more opportunity than the sport I
was in volleyball so like there's a bit
more opportunity and like um I did court
volleyball beach volleyball there's a
bit more
um and fighting I've heard female female
Fighters actually get paid an okay
amount so this female fighter won some
boxing UFC type stuff I don't really get
it uh pull the clip
[Applause]
if they're gonna do anything it's the
cleanest shots
[Applause]
so women will be like respect us
why don't you take us seriously we can
do anything a man can do then when we do
it
we take off our clothes
we take off our clothes which you know
at least she did figure this out really
the only way and I've thought about this
the only way women can really make money
at sports is through two things one
social media so Vlogs about the teams
getting rich parents to train your kids
and unfortunately taking our clothes off
all of the women's sports would be
profitable tomorrow
if women started taking off their
clothes now I don't say this as I wish
this would happen but I'm just a realist
guys if women started taking off their
clothes
they would in fact make more money but
what baffles me is we will whine about
inequality wine that we are not paid the
same and then this is what we do when we
get to the foreground but Pearl this
doesn't happen in other Industries right
a woman can just do anything a man can
do a woman can just a woman is our women
are so respectable that we come into a
man's world and we just dominate we just
kill it
ah